final part the puddles initially to
saturday is deep and the evaporation
constant if the rate at which things are
the fabric I'd guess to pity unlike
temperature and wind all I kind of thing
is that value there find how long it
takes for the puddle to evaporate okay
so here's part 3 how I find out how long
it takes for this puddle to evaporate
okay so when you have a look at this
right it would be it would be not that
not that unusual to say okay well the
rate that I'm going at is that 0.025
that's been mentioned okay um however I
have a problem with that which is that
they haven't said like just look really
carefully at the wording of the question
right they've said um the evaporation
constant is known to be k equals that or
not the evaporation constant what is the
evaporation reason it's not the rate
necessarily at which it's getting
smaller and smaller it's this number
here right it's it's what's proportional
between these two beams so actually
there's an extra step i need to do I
don't have an expression for H here
right I have an expression for D H MDT
so how do I climb up out of an
expression for change suspicious I'm
going to integrate ok so I'm going to
say H equals and where is my th other
tables just it's just a guy right so
it's going to be I'm dealing with H a
deal with edge of the moon so that's
that so the line I've got get to the
right pane is on is k which is 0.025 we
just wait to talk yeah degree so from
this it's just a concert so I'm just
going to get a factor of tea but it's
indefinite so I have a constant
so how do i work out wisconsin yeah the
question is given the information right
the fancy weber state is you've been
given initial conditions right so you
can say when T equals 0 what's H equal
to now you just got to be slightly
careful here the answer is too but it's
not too because the question says to its
too because 4-2 is too what's more minus
2 so remember that thing I dealing with
is H right that's this guy up here so if
the depth of this starts at two then
this must be for take away to right so
if for instance my puddle started at one
centimeter when T equals e to h would
not be one what 1h baby it would be
three if you don't take away one right
question right we got we got from that
wherever there yeah so you do need that
piece of information and they've kind of
you haven't explicitly said are yet it's
for but I think we can conclude that
from that equation so yes just be
careful like I said it's not just about
the numbers but knowing how to use them
and that's an easy trap to fall into we
kind of got lucky but if you did it
wrong and just said oh h equals two
because the question is it to you just
have by coincidence got it right well we
could have changed it to def one then
three aware okay so i'm going to use
that and i'm going to say therefore
0.025 x 0 that's me putting in time 0
plus my constant equals 2 so that's why
I see it was too and I don't think you
should leave it to this line I think you
should show these a bit ly simple but
these important steps that demonstrate
so therefore H equals
and on the basis of that equation I'm
leaving in phenix I think you can you
can work this out what do I want H to be
when does the puddle evaporate it's when
there's no water left which means that H
remember was growing and growing and
going so you want H to be equal to four
and when H equals four you're going to
get an answer out for this so what a job
a problem Rory which is 80 I believe
Justin okay uh well yeah but we've
actually taken out so maybe i will put
this land with you i'm going to say in
the puddle that rates or the pole how's
that for any and then you stay q value
right and then you just go ahead and
solve
wait